all right up next is going to be Mahana
in Orlando hey Mahana how are you better
than I deserve mr. Ramsey how are you
just the same how can I help I've been
missing your show now for about seven
months and I'm on baby step one I have
about seven hundred dollars saved I make
about forty five thousand a year my wife
was out of work for about eight months
and I was providing for the five of us
we just had a newborn she's six months
old her name is my Ella and I am stuck
in the position of deciding to get out
of renting and purchasing a home we
spoke to a mortgage broker who
pre-approved us for 300,000 and we found
a few homes that are under that price
and I'm not sure which step to take if
we should continue going in the
direction of renting until we get our
debts paid off or if we should buy a
home and the reason why is because our
marital relationship is kind of on a
bumpy road in the D words been thrown
around a few times and I'm not sure
financially nor merrily which way I
should go yeah well let me just tell you
having kids in buying a house does not
make a bumpy marriage better yeah and so
we need to solve that before we start
making permanent decisions like kids and
houses so on if the D word is being
thrown around that means you guys need
to be in good marriage counseling and a
good thing to do while you're working on
that stuff is work on the debt I would
tell you to be debt-free and have your
emergency fund in place before you buy a
house now that may not be real popular
advice but I don't really care if it's
popular it's the proper and smart and
wise thing to do because when you buy a
house and you have no money and you have
debt payments coming out of your ears
the house is no longer a blessing it
becomes a curse and you add a little bit
of marital strife to that now you've got
a real mess on your hands so I would
touch the tap the brakes on buying the
house for right now I'd concentrate my
financial energies on two things one
getting out of debt and two learning to
work together and the learning to work
together part would be part of you guys
healing and
working on your overall relationship how
long have you been married we've been
together for three years married for two
years and it's been a struggle trying to
get her on the baby step program with me
okay are you guys on a good church yes
we we've listened to a few podcasts from
a1 pastor we enjoy named Steven Furtick
then we go to a great church down here
in Naples called destiny Church uncle
young Stevens a friend of mine
so um he's a great preacher yes make
sure you're in a good Church and your
local church there you might contact the
pastor and say hey we need to sit down
with somebody and work on some basic
relationship things because you know
marriage license doesn't come with a
handbook and most of us I've been
married 34 years dude not going to tell
you there's been times in our marriage
we bi killed each other it was not fun
and Sharon laughs and says we've been
married 34 years but at 27 good years of
marriage you know you know
my point is everybody has what you got
at some bo ain't just about and but it's
not going to get better on its own the
cars are not going to get clean unless
you wash it right and then you can't
just leave it out in the rain that's not
going to work out for you and so you
guys treat this like it was a you know
something that you need to learn because
you do and I would work on that and
encourage you in your marriage and get
your pastor on board with you and start
listening to marriage things out there
you know Reed Henry cloud and read less
Parrott and read a leg rich is a book a
love and respect is a good book and I'll
give you a copy of that one as a matter
of fact I'll throw it in right now he's
a friend of mine too a great writer so
that's the kind of stuff you need to do
and I'll tell you what you go through
Financial Peace University - I'll pay
for that maybe that will help the
marriage part of the money thing but
don't buy a house until you get out of
debt and get your marriage off the edge
of a rocky shores this is the Dave
Ramsey show hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]